quand le monde aura besoin d'être sauvé, il faudra
l'équipe la plus élitiste du monde, le skipper
Kowalski Rico et le privé étaient l'
élitiste de l'élite les créateurs de
Madagascar d'accord les garçons c'est la
mission que nous avons préparée toute notre
vie restez calmes pingouins vous
êtes  maintenant sous la protection du
lapin Northwind Dibble me nous
n'allons nulle part avec vous le vent du nord
est une élite interspécifique d'
infiltration un groupe de travail d'élite interspécifique d'infiltration
dédié à son aide dédié à
dédié à aider quiconque Kok
se menotte mmm skipper nous avons  il faut être à 5
miles de haut, ce qui limite à peu près nos
options, je fais mes propres options,
un capitaine de mouvement brillant, mais maintenant
nous semblons être en dehors du jeu.
jouer à l'
oiseau directement connecter
DreamWorks Penguins of Madagascar
maintenant nous parlons allons au travail
400 mètres 300 mètres parlent américain
Kowalski désolé monsieur 218 mètres d'accord alors
c'est clair w  ce que nous devons faire ensuite qui
se sent bien
[Musique]